hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game it's from
yesterday's uh gran chester blitz
section it's vishwanathan
versus yanipanishi and this is a game
from round 14. a lot of you guys have
suggested it so let's check it out the
tournament has finished and there of
course are
a lot of cool games to be covered so do
use hashtag suggestion
uh and i will go over uh or your
suggestion and check out
the the game you've um uh you've had in
mind so here
uh anand with the white pieces opens
with e4
sorry about that uh nipple replies with
c5 he goes for the sicilian defense we
have knight to f3
e6 and now d4 so nothing uh out of the
ordinary here just captures captures
knight to c
c6 knight to c3 and now a6 so we are in
the timeout variation of the sicilian
knight captures on c6 b captures now
black with a very strong center here
uh preparing to strike with the d5 and
on and place queen to f3 here
so of course if white allows it the
black will do it so here we have d5
and now queen to g3 so this is um
basically the only move that's uh that's
played here you hinder the development
of
black's dark square bishop and your
queen is very active here controlling
the b8 square so rook to b8 can't really
be played
uh something that black would really
want to do so here we have
f5 now striking in the center sort of a
stonehenge for
formation stonewall formation here and
we have e captures on f5 we have e
captures and
now uh there is the game in the database
where bishop to g5 was played
uh it's also a game that was uh uh
played by nepo and nakamura
had this position against yanni pomeshi
in this year's magnus crossing
invitational in march
the game ended in a draw uh where uh
hikaru played bishop to g5 but here
anand plays bishop to f4
and it is now as of move tended we have
a completely new game
uh so let's see how nipple continues we
have knight to f6
and bishop to e2 now ready to castle and
now
rook to a7 and it's often the case when
you have uh for example the bishop here
attacking the square
you can't really grab hold of the
semi-open b file you're going to play
rook to a7
and now if needed in the future you can
even play some like rook to b7 to grab
hold of the b file but
it's small the rook is most likely
coming to the uh only open file on the
board which is the e
file so here we have castles by anand
and now
king the f7 by nipple now now he wants
to play h6 g5
uh develop the the dark square bishop
and only then get the rook into the game
but the king as you'll see will be very
safe here
so rook 8 to d1 and now h6 preparing g5
so anand plays bishop to e5 not allowing
g5 to come with an attack on the bishop
here
so g5 uh still and now rook after e1
we have bishop to g7 and now bishop to
f1 the bishop is uh very nicely tucked
in here as a defensive piece
it also uh well just uh slices
the the board in half attacking that a6
pawn if black ever stops defending it
and also you make room for the e for
this rook to control the e file
so rook the e7 now preparing to double
up here with rook
h to e8 and now bishop to d4 offering a
trade of rooks
so rook h to e8 and now rook captures on
e7 we have queen captures on e7 now
nipple controls
the e file but now queen to d3 anand
just centralizes the queen as he knows
moves like f4 are coming
so f4 by nippo and now a3 and here we
have
a5 and now how do you how do you
continue this game
for anand well uh you should always uh
strive towards improving the
the quality not the quality but uh maybe
the activity of your pieces so here
knight's the a4 the knight is now coming
to c5 and it definitely makes sense
it's gonna be hard for uh for black to
to prevent this and also you're gonna be
nicely controlling this bishop here uh
from c5 so here we have bishop to g4
attacking the rook but anand says now
the problem i i even wanted to play f3
here at some point
we have bishop back to d7 and now knight
to c5 and this is now a beautifully
placed knight
uh we have bishop to c8 not allowing
this tension to exist in white's favor
and the queen to c3 now putting some
pressure on this bishop here if the
knight ever moves but also just
attacking the a5 pawn
and here if nipple wanted nipple could
uh maybe play queen to c7 defend the a5
pawn and the game just continues but
it's uh still
uh not maybe the the greatest of
positions at some point the white will
launch forward with b4 and he's gonna
start creating something on the queen
side
so nipple not interested in a passive
position like this he goes
g4 and now uh what do you play here well
now if you go after the pawn just g
captures on f3 and it's not looking all
that great for white
so instead after this um uh
after this uh g4 move we have knight to
d3 by anand now putting pressure on the
f4 pawn
and also you can play knight to e5 at
any point to close off the e file
so here nipple plays g captures on f3 we
have g
captures on f3 and now knight to d7 i'm
grabbing control of the e5 square so
white
doesn't have this knight's the e5 move
uh and now uh
leaving the bishop here undefended so as
you can see the bishop is attacked twice
by the queen and by the bishop
uh but it doesn't matter if the bishop
captures then rook to g8 will pin the
bishop the king is still on g1 and
nipple will be able to win back his
piece
and says okay i don't think i have
anything better he plays bishop captures
on g7
uh and now nepo pins the bishop with
rook to g8
the problem is uh there is a better move
but it's uh it's blitz of course so you
you can't always find a better move
uh but queen the e3 check uh was better
uh simply because it prevents king to h1
and
the the h1 square is a key uh defensive
resource for ireland here in this
in this position now you have to play
king to g2 you can't really play king to
h1 because then the f3
upon uh will fall with check and then
the rook can fall and it's just a
losing position for white so here you're
gonna have to play king to g2 and
now rook to g8 is much much stronger
however in the game nipple played rook
to g8 right away and now comes
king to h1 so now the king is very safe
here
rook captures on g7 uh winning back the
piece but now queen captures on c6 and
as you can see
this position is much much different
from the one uh if the black queen
had delivered to check here on the e3
square so queen to g5 now we reach the
position from the thumbnail
if this ever you know reaches the
thumbnail uh nipple is now threatening
queen to g1 check but on and just place
bishop to h3 now the rook defends the g1
square so there's no checkmate the
bishop covers this square
and okay you are putting some pressure
here even though the bishop can never
really capture
because then queen to g2 would be
checkmate so here we have knights the b6
now
uh kind of offering the knight and here
nippo is attacking anand's bishop on h3
and we already said that the bishop
can't really move otherwise you're
getting checkmated and it seems like
uh it seems like it's over it seems like
nipple really
was able to you know break through the
position here but there is one move and
it's
it's uh it's such an amazing move that
uh well
uh feel free to pause the video and try
to find this idea while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
not doing anything weird even though
here it's it's very hard to
to find something weird but for those of
you who are able to do it
congratulations as the move is
uh rook to g1 that of course is a lie
that you can't play that uh bishop to g4
and there is something beautiful about
solving the position by just moving the
piece one square
and here although it looks really weird
it's not because after bishop captures
and pawn captures which was played in
the game
you don't have queen captures now with
the deadly threats because knights the
e5 check would win the queen
so uh nippo can't really do this after f
captures on g4 he sidesteps with the
king king to g8 now he of course would
very much enjoy capturing this pawn
but not knights to f2 now the pawn is
defended and
there's no way for nepal to break
through so here rook to g6
attacks the queen also the knight here
and now queen the e8 with
check king to h7 and now rook to e1
preparing to
start delivering some deadly checks so
rook to g7
and now b3 just uh taking control of
these squares so the knight really can't
uh
join the game this way so the knight has
to find a different route
we have knight steady seven and now
queen to e6
so what do you play here we have knight
to f6 bringing the knight to help out
with the defense but now you've given up
the e5 square so rook to e5 attacks the
black queen
queen to g6 now queen to f5 offering a
queen trade
and here uh nippo should really consider
just
capturing either on g4 or just trading
queens for example knight captures and
g4
characters captures and captures and try
and play this um
this end game where white is of course
uh and of course rook captures on g4
uh we're going to play rook captures on
d5 and white it will be up a pawn but
it's a rook sand game you know perhaps
perhaps it's possible to hold this but
he uh you know
doesn't think so it's a very ugly
position maybe white can even get
nice two connected past pawns here so
instead after this queen to f5
he just plays rook to c7 he says okay
i'm going after uh
the c2 pawn and now if you want you can
trade queens but now anan says
but now there's something better i'm
just capture the pawn on f4 it's a free
pawn
uh because if you capture on c2 then you
no longer have control of the seventh
rank and then my rook
joins the seventh rank and we all know
what a rook on the seventh rank is
called
so here where nepal doesn't really have
a choice now he's down two pawns he has
to go for material rook captures on c2
but now just rook to e7 with check and
there's really not uh not a lot of ways
you can defend this king h8 we have
rooked the e6 now threatening to win the
knight here
so king to g7 defending and now just h3
now the knight can move as the g4 pawn
is nicely protected
we have queen to f7 unpinning and now
comes queen to e5 again pinning the
knight here
so queen and not just pinning the eye
but also threatening rook to e7 to win
the queen so queen to f8 will rook the
e7 check
king to g8 now queen to e6 with check
and now there's uh
no more no more way to prolong this we
have rook to f7 now attacking the queen
and the knight
and here nepal can resign but uh he
doesn't he decides to give up the queen
for two
for this rook and knight so queen
captures queen captures and
rook captures on f2 and maybe it's still
possible he does have a pass pawn maybe
he can push it maybe good things can
still happen
but now king the g1 attacking the rook
rook to f4
and now queen to g6 just threatening
queen captures and then
it's gonna be check and you're gonna
lose the rook so rook back to f3 but now
queen captures with check
king g8 uh king j8 with queen back to g6
with
check king to f8 and now uh anand played
king to g2 and he was in this position
uh on move 53
that ian ponchi resigned the game and
what an amazing
victory for for ananda in round 14 of
the
of the blitz section of the second day
of the creation grand chess to wrap it
uh so here you resign because your rook
is under attack and there's really no
good way to save it uh because well
these three squares are covered by the
by the king
these uh this square is covered by the
queen and the only square you have left
to keep defending the knight is this
square
but like we said queen to h6 will just
pick up the rook if the rook is on f4
when
check is delivered so of course there's
no more uh
i think the things to try here it's just
completely lost position so of course uh
nipple resigned
so an excellent game and the brilliant
tournament for vishwanathan anand
who in the end finished in second place
uh two points
behind maksim bashir lagrave i will show
you the standings just so you guys uh
uh get a glimpse of it so there you have
it uh maxime bashar al-agrav
winning the tournament with 23 points uh
followed by vishwanathan anand with
21 points uh there was an interesting
moment uh
i think it was uh in the penultimate
round or or maybe maybe one round before
that where kasparov was facing maxine
vashilagrav
and had kasparov uh had kasparov
defeated the maxim
he would uh well he would allow anand
basically to
to uh you know uh overtake maksim as the
leader of the tournament
and kasparov was uh sorry because paro
was even leading uh
as he was uh he had a rooks end game and
he was up upon he had a rook in five
points max team had rook in four pawns
and then all of a sudden kasparov uh
gave up one point and then lost on time
so
that was very unfortunate for anand as
that that was uh
if kasparov was able to you know do
something there even grab a half a point
uh from from
steam then it would it would definitely
help uh ananda
uh you know maybe overtake him as the
leader
but okay in third place we have anish
giri uh uh
uh in four place yani pony she tied with
young shisht of duda and then with
nineteen points shakhtar mamidarov
with 18 alexander grisha with 15 and a
half anton korobov
uh in uh with 12 and a half in ninth
place kasparov and chadric as they have
joined points
since one of them played the rapid
section one of them played the blitz
section
uh so as you can see here uh shotish won
10 points because part of only two and a
half which you know
not all that great and in last place we
have
j j v f with 10 and a half points
yes that that is how we do it now uh so
yeah
once again i hope you guys enjoyed that
that was a very very nice game thank you
for suggesting it and of course you
should use
a hashtag suggestion to suggest uh even
more nice games
uh so uh i would like to thank robert
araton and jim alboy cruzada.com and
christopher marchetti for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of basically
everything that's happening in the chess
world
so thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day